do beat sheets work I think having an
outline is an excellent idea I do know
writers who don't need them I think that
needs something in and these are going
to be writers I speak of writers I've
worked with so they are tend to already
be devotees of using the nutshell
technique and that might be all they do
they won't do of each sheet they'll just
do a nutshell technique form and as long
as they are true to that they'll have it
and it's nice and solid and maybe
they'll work with me one on one to make
sure they're there nutshells solid
they'll tack it up on their bulletin
board and then they'll write from that
and they don't do any other beat sheet
or outlining I think most writers need a
beat sheet or outline they need more
detail than that but it varies as long
as you so as long as you have a solid
structure you don't necessarily need
more than this you know the idea this
isn't drawn to scale but you'll see that
most of my structure things are in act 1
and act 3 and the only thing that's an
act 2 is just one element here and act 2
is actually twice as long so I don't
have a bunch of structure requirements I
don't have required beats in your act to
even act - even though act 2 is twice as
long I strongly believe that if you
properly structure things in act 1 and
you properly structure things in act 3
it does all the heavy lifting of
supporting your act - even though your
act 2 is twice as long as long as you
maintain conflict so I know lots of
writers who hate meat sheets
and and that's what can I really throw
it out I was like you absolutely can if
you don't like doing a beachy you don't
find that helpful you can as long as you
find a nice solid structure and you stay
true to it this should be enough to
guide you as long as even have conflict
I do think most writers need more detail
and so I you know but it it it's up to
the right or a little bit so more detail
I don't I don't think it's a good idea
to do a super detailed one because you
want to allow a certain amount of
discovery on the page
I mean that's why I like having the
looser structure of the nutshell to
begin with we have a couple things you
gotta hit if it shift from them then
you're screwing up a story but if you
say solid to these elements that might
not might be all you need and you could
just write and live on the page as long
as you hit those couple of moments or
perhaps you need a little bit more
structure a little bit of an outline or
a beat sheet but I don't recommend doing
super detailed ones there's a thing I
call beat sheet
fatigue where people just spend too much
time on that particularly if you're
getting feedback if you're sharing if
you're nut shell your your I'm sorry
your beat sheet or your outline with
your writing group or people like that
you maybe get feedback on maybe like an
eight page one but anything longer than
that it's getting into so much detail
but we'd rather read the script at that
point you know a beachy ultimately is
for your benefit anyway so what it's
whatever you need if you need a little
more structure than just this and like I
said I think most people need a little
bit more I think it's a pretty good idea
to have a loose guide of you know this
happens I think this happens then this
happens in this happens but kind of
loose so that you can discover somewhat
on the page what about conflict fatigue
what about someone adding too much
conflict right away but there's no real
purpose it's just it's just creating
friction because the writer thinks they
need it but then it doesn't really lend
itself to the story do you see that a
lot or do you see not enough conflict I
see not enough a complet conflict more
often as a problem what you're
describing there being too much it
sounds to me like it would be the case
of somebody who hadn't really figured
out what the story is and they're just
they just know screenwriter 101 I'm just
a conflict right so they just have a
bunch of conflict but there's not
necessarily a purpose so it sounds like
that might be a little situational or
episodic but I'd have to kind of see
that in a case
case that basis
you